Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Lidia Cámara de la Fuente
En el tercer milenio
antes de nuestra era,
los reyes mesopotámicos registran e
interpretan sueños en tablillas de cera.
Mil años después,
los antiguos egipcios
escribieron un libro de sueños
listando más de cien sueños comunes
y sus significados.
Y en los años posteriores,
no hemos dejado de preguntarnos
por qué soñamos.
Pero, después de mucha
investigación científica,
de avances tecnológicos y persistencia,
aun no tenemos respuestas definitivas,
pero sí algunas teorías interesantes.
Soñamos para cumplir nuestros deseos.
En el año 1900,
Sigmund Freud propuso que, si bien todos
los sueños, incluso las pesadillas,
son un conjunto de imágenes de
nuestra vida consciente cotidiana,
tienen también un significado simbólico
referido al cumplimiento de
nuestros deseos subconscientes.
Freud teorizó que todo lo que
recordamos al despertar de un sueño
es una representación simbólica
de nuestros pensamientos primitivos
inconscientes, urgencias y deseos.
Freud creía que analizando
esos elementos recordados,
el contenido inconsciente
se revelaría a la mente consciente
y así se podrían abordar y resolver
los problemas psicológicos
derivados de su represión.
Soñamos para recordar.
Para aumentar el rendimiento
de ciertas funciones mentales,
es bueno dormir,
pero soñar durante el sueño es mejor.
En el 2010 investigadores descubrieron
que los sujetos sorteaban mucho mejor
un complejo laberinto 3D
si habían dormido soñando con
el laberinto antes del segundo intento.
De hecho, tenían 10 veces más éxito
que los que solo pensaban en el
laberinto despiertos entre intentos,
y que los que dormían,
pero no soñaban con el laberinto.
Los investigadores teorizan que
cientos procesos de la memoria
pueden ocurrir solo mientras dormimos,
y nuestros sueños son una señal
de que ocurren estos procesos.
Soñamos para olvidar.
Existen unas 10 000 billones
de conexiones neuronales
en la arquitectura del cerebro.
Estas se crean a partir de lo que
piensas y de todo lo que haces.
Una teoría neurobiológica del sueño,
de 1983, llamada aprendizaje inverso,
sostiene que mientras dormimos
y sobre todo en los ciclos de sueño REM,
el neocórtex revisa
estas conexiones neuronales
y desconecta las innecesarias.
Sin este proceso de desaprendizaje,
que se traduce en los sueños,
el cerebro podría saturarse
de conexiones inútiles
y los pensamientos parásitos
podrían interrumpir el pensamiento
que necesitas cuando estás despierto.
Soñamos para mantener
funcionando al cerebro.
La teoría de la activación continua
propone que los sueños surgen
de la necesidad constante del cerebro de
crear y consolidar recuerdos a largo plazo
para funcionar correctamente.
Así, cuando la entrada externa
es menor de un cierto nivel,
como cuando duermes,
el cerebro activa automáticamente
la generación de datos a partir
de sus almacenes de memoria,
que se presentan como los
pensamientos y sentimientos
que se experimentan en los sueños.
En otras palabras,
los sueños podrían ser un protector de
pantalla al azar que el cerebro enciende
para no apagarse por completo.
Soñamos para ensayar.
Es muy común soñar con situaciones
peligrosos y amenazantes,
y la teoría del ensayo
por instinto primitivo
sostiene que el contenido de un sueño
es significativo para su propósito.
Se trate de una noche llena de ansiedad
por un oso que te persigue en el bosque
o de luchar con un ninja
en un callejón oscuro,
estos sueños te permiten practicar
tus instintos de lucha o huida
y permiten tenerlos a mano en caso
de necesitarlos en la vida real.
Pero no tiene por qué
ser siempre desagradable.
Por ejemplo, soñar con
tu vecina atractiva
podría también poner en práctica
tu instinto reproductivo.
Soñamos para sanar.
Los neurotransmisores del estrés
del cerebro están mucho menos activos
durante la fase REM del sueño,
incluso durante los sueños
con experiencias traumáticas,
y eso lleva a algunos
investigadores a teorizar
que uno de los propósitos del sueño
es abordar experiencias dolorosas
para permitir la curación psicológica.
Revisar eventos traumáticos en sueños
con menos estrés mental
puede darte una perspectiva más clara
y la capacidad de procesarlos mejor
en formas psicológicamente sanas.
El estrés postraumático o un estado de
ánimo alterado, a menudo impiden dormir
y eso ha llevado a algunos científicos
a creer que la falta de sueño
puede ser un factor que contribuye
a esas enfermedades.
Soñamos para resolver problemas.
Sin las restricciones de la realidad
ni las reglas de la lógica convencional,
en tus sueños, la mente puede crear
escenarios de manera ilimitada
para ayudarte a captar problemas
y formular soluciones que podrías
no considerar al estar despierto.
John Steinbeck lo llamó
comité del sueño,
y hay investigaciones que demuestran
la efectividad del sueño
en la resolución de problemas.
Así descubrió también el
célebre químico August Kekulé
la estructura de la molécula de benceno,
y es la razón por la que a veces
la mejor solución para un problema
se consigue yendo a dormir.
Estas son solo algunas de
las teorías más prominentes.
Conforme la tecnología aumenta la
capacidad de comprensión del cerebro,
es posible que un día
descubramos su razón definitiva.
Pero hasta que eso suceda,
sigamos soñando.